we openly talked today about what
needs to be changed in the army, urgent changes, I
offered General Zuluzh to continue to be
together in the Ukrainian
state team, I will be grateful for his consent
Today I made a decision to update the
leadership of the armed forces of
Ukraine This is not about the last name and even more so
not about politics  this is about the system of our
army, about the management of the armed forces of
Ukraine and about the involvement of the experience of the combat
commanders of this war, dear
people. From today to the leadership of the
armed forces of Ukraine, all of them
are being considered for leadership positions in the army
and will serve under the
guidance of the most experienced
Ukrainian commander, the combat commander,
Colonel General Oleksandr
Syrsky. He has  successful
defense experience conducted the Kyiv defense
operation He also has a successful offensive experience of the
Kharkiv liberation
operation I appointed Colonel-General
Syrian as the commander-in-chief of the armed
forces of Ukraine in the second year of this war we won the
Black Sea we won the winter we proved
that we can regain control over the
Ukrainian sky but unfortunately we could not
to achieve the goals of our state on the ground,
we must honestly say that the feeling of
stagnation especially in the southern directions and the
difficulties in the battles in Donetsk have affected the
public mood.
war commanders from scratch have to
implement their special experience at the
level of the entire army in
[applause]
leadership